à cinquante quatre jours des élections
présidentielles le livre intitulé reds
est une bombe pour dans notre chambre il
se base sur dix huit entretiens
enregistrés entre le président et le
journaliste bob ou joe 2 décembre 2019 à
juillet 2020
dès le 7 février d'or notre chambre
relate aux journalistes la conversation
qu'il a eue avec xi jinping sur le
coronavirus le virus se propage dans
l'air dit il ce n'est pas au contact
c'est plus mortelle qu'une grosse grille
il répète que c'est un virus mortel qui
peut affecter 5% de la population
il avertit aussi que ce ne sont pas
juste les personnes âgées qui peuvent
être touchées mais aussi les jeunes
puis le président explique sa stratégie
aux journalistes j'ai toujours voulu
minimiser de virus dit il je le mets
nuisent encore pour ne pas créer de
panique en campagne électorale au
michigan jobs hayden ne mâche pas ses
mots c'est ignoble dit il le président
savait et a menti il doit il aurait pu
sauver des milliers de vie ajoutent-ils
en affirmant que dans notre chambre est
inapte être président des états unis il
faire un effort au début de la pandémie
dans notre chambre affirmé que le virus
disparaîtrait de lui-même au printemps
car il fera plus chaud et qu'il fallait
le traiter comme une grippe a
aujourd'hui le pays a le triste record
mondial de cas de coronavirus soit plus
de 6 millions avec plus de 190 mille
morts
les etats unis qui représentent 4% de la
population mondiale détiennent 20% des
cas de coronavirus le livre révèle
également que selon le docteur pham chi
dans notre chemin déficit d'attention et
que tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est sa
réélection le moins un an
si on avait su que le virus se
transmettait par voie aérienne
on aurait agi plus tôt et sauver des
vies dit le gouverneur du new jersey
mais dans notre chambre est
imperturbable et admet qu'il ne voulait
pas semer la panique comme sa gestion de
la pandémie a déjà été sévèrement
critiquée par la majorité de la
population
aujourd'hui les américains apprennent
que leur président connaissait les
dangers du virus et ne les en a pas
informés alors que le bilan des morts ne
fait que s'alourdir
ici à 0 2 les guerres guise radio canada
montréal